this is a production of Cornell
University I'm going to start us off
with talking a little bit about myself
and where I come from and the people
that I come from um so I grew up in a
trailer at the edge of the Tanto
National Forest in New River Arizona um
so think desert Wilderness like down
here this is my first day of school ever
um I'm an enrolled member of the OA
Lakota nation in South Dakota um that's
where my family and I would spend a lot
of summers in the house that it's been
in my family for over 200 years and on
homelands for time in Memorial before
that uh my mom is from bonpo Thailand my
mom's sitting over there um it's where
we get the PO part of our names and
uh uh and through a long and winding
Journey uh that I won't fully get into
here that was filled with a lot of
Adventure a little bit of being
homeschooled and a small stint of being
homeless and living in a tent my family
and I I moved to Hawaii and that's where
Ed mentioned I got my bachelor's degree
at the University of Hawaii at Hilo and
after that I moved back to one of my
homelands to get my Master's Degree at
South Dakota state I'm the first person
in my family or my mom's family to have
gone to college and the first person in
all of my family to get any sort of
graduate degree and I'm not telling you
this because I want you to feel sorry
for me or think differently about me or
my talk it's just that given my life and
my cultural background I feel like a
statistical anomaly every time I enter
academic spaces and especially here at
Cornell and so I know I was never meant
to be here um but uh I hope that today I
can tell you a little bit about what
I've been able to do in the past six
years and how much this means to um the
people and places that I come from so
for the past few years um I have been
working on Maze and Maze is a fantastic
species to understand the genetic basis
of complex traits and so ma is an annual
outcrossing
species that's deployed with 10
chromosomes and globally it's grown on
around 200 million
hectares um and it serves as a fantastic
system to study the genetic basis of
complex traits uh to learn about Gene
regulation and then also validate all of
those findings within
fields and so my project is uh split
into three different parts the first is
on elucidating the patterns of Pat tropy
the second is on uh the regulatory
impact of tees and the last is on field
testing and so for the First on piot
tropy um it's helpful to start off with
some definitions because p tropy is
still really confusing even to me so uh
Pat tropy is a single Locus that can
affect multiple different seemingly
unrelated traits and there's a lot of
different ways that this Pat tropy can
manifest itself the first is with
biological or horizontal pliot tropy um
that's where you can have a single
causal variant with the star that then
impacts two different traits you can
have mediated pliot tropy that uh where
uh one trait is then causal for
another and then you can have spous Pat
tropy where regions of really strong LD
make it hard to distinguish uh what
causal variance is leading to what
trait and in maze there are a few
examples of verified Pat tropy and these
are things like teent Branch one one of
the major domestication genes uh that
impacts lateral branching inflorescence
length and Branch length and there's
also one of the major flowering time
genes vgt1 that impacts flowering time
Leaf number and PL
tiddes and so looking across larger uh
sets of genes and not only domestication
or flowering genes the only real pliot
tropy that has able to been or be found
is within a trait sharing the same
developmental unit and so things like
tassel architecture and ear architecture
like inflorescence traits there's also
some pliot tropy between flowering and
leaf traits where you need to have a
certain number of leaves before
flowering initiates and then that life
cycle finishes off and there's further
evidence of this with uh sorghum and
Maze where the only Pat tropy that's
really found is in very few Snips um and
they are typically between again things
that are sharing the same developmental
unit um within a lot of the human
genetic studies they've been able to
look at things like how pliot tropy is
more associated with more highly
expressed genes that are expressed
across more tissues along with DNA
accessibility and DNA conservation but
in maze a lot of these things are
largely unknown and so in this project
uh there two main questions were what
are the actual patterns of pliot tropy
do um they kind of mimic some of these
large effect domestication or flowering
time Loi or uh are they different in
large standing natural variation
populations and the second is can pliot
tropy be modeled and if so what kind of
biological and noise terms actually
explain the amount of Pat tropy
present and so in order to do this we
collected every single published
phenotype within the ma n and 282
populations and this came out to be over
120,000 different traits and they were
for things like RNA expression values
across different tissues metabolite data
and also field traits so like the
traditional plant height uh kernel row
number and inflorescence
architecture and so with these traits we
perform gwas using rassel and then for
our pliot tropy metric we counted the
number of unique traits mapping to each
interval and so what this look like for
Interval a for example there's two
shapes that map to it and so it's two
unique traits uh for Interval B it would
just be one C is our least fotopic
interval so it's zero and then e is our
most pliot Tropic interval with three
unique traits mapping to it um in order
to get a kind of null Baseline of what
no pliot tropy would look like we
permuted our traits anywhere from five
to 10 times ran gwas again and then got
our null counts of what no pliot tropy
looked
like and so for all the plots that I'm
going to show you all the types of fot
tropy are mixed up we didn't try to
distinguish between any one of these and
so it's just a a mixed bag of
everything
uh realized I could turn the captions
off okay uh so to Prime you for the plot
that I'm going to show you um this shows
on the xaxis the log number observed
over fudu traits and the y- AIS is the
number of intervals and the main thing
is is that anything that falls along the
dashed line means that there's oh no
pliot tropy um anything to the left of
the dash line means that there's noise
and anything to the right means there's
sum and so for the N Field traits around
1% of intervals actually show evidence
for Pat tropy and it controls around
five different
traits um looking across all the other
populations and trait types um this
number varies from 1 to 32% of intervals
controlling anywhere from 5 to 400
traits and even though this seems like a
lot in later slides I'll show you that
this is primarily due to noise terms imp
parted through the gwos
process and so now that we know that
there is variability in plot tropy um we
kind of we we bring back a lot of the
terms that have been important within
the human genetics models like gene
expression uh DNA accessibility DNA
conservation and some noise terms that
are imparted through gws like uh the
mean amount of LD within the interval
we're looking at the size of the
interval and then also the number of
input gws Snips that we
used
um and we put all these things together
and build a random forest model to
determine what are the most important
variables in explaining fot
tropy and this shows that um primarily
statistical noise terms in part of the
Gs are the most important and so again
these are things like Snips for Interval
the physical size and the average amount
of LD of much lower biological
importance are things like sequence
conservation RNA expression or um
protein expression and a very similar
trend is shown across all the other
populations and trait types that we
looked
at and so altogether um LD and noise
terms explain Pat tropy much better than
any other biological feature or term and
we hypothesize that most descriptions of
plyopic genes in the past are probably
really confounded by linkage because
it's it's a hard thing to break out of
and there's a lot of
it and so the key takeaways from this
project um were Pat tropy are or is is
not as common as we previously thought
and the 1 to 32% of plyopic intervals
that we found can originate from sites
with varying chromatin accessibility
expression and conservation levels most
observed petrop is noise and so LD will
really mess up any uh Pat tropy
estimates that we get and last Pat tropy
in crop plants is highly constrained by
Evolution and so the load of modest
level Supply tropy actually kind of
makes sense because it would allow for
selection to more easily fine-tune and
adap ADT varieties to different
locations and I like to think about if
you had a single Gene that controlled 50
different traits it's much harder to
work with that single Gene as opposed to
50 genes controlling 50 different
traits and so even though Pat tropy
might have had little genome wide impact
the the impact of trait curation and the
gwas results themselves had a really
large impact and I've been lucky to be a
part of numerous different papers that
have used these traits and phenotypes to
predict traits with RNA expression
values or look at how they can be
explained by conserved non-coding
regions Upstream of jees so that was
good the next project that I worked on
um was looking at the impact of tees on
gene expression and so a study I was a
major contributor to in 2021 showed that
around 34% of the expression variation
in genes can be explained by CIS
regulatory variants and these are
variants that occur within in genes or
right next to genes and one of the
long-standing questions has been how
much do transposable elements or tees
themselves contribute to this gene
expression
variation um I really oh yeah and it
kind of makes sense in maze because 85%
of the genome is made up of transposable
elements or these repetitive sequences
and a famous example of this is the
bronze one Locus and Maze where the
different rows correspond to different
maze inbred lines and the yellow bars um
are transposons and the orange or the
red triangles are DNA transposons and
you can see that the ma genome is
absolutely littered with transposable
elements throughout its inner genic
space in terms of tees that contribute
to gene expression uh tiente Branch one
is another really famous example where a
hopscotch retrotransposon brings in an
enhancer that then increases gene
expression by around two times and this
leads to the differences in plant
architecture between tiente and Maze
um and bringing in an enhancer is just
one way in which a te can potentially
impact gene expression uh you can
imagine with the bronze one example you
could get a te that inserts into an
Exxon and leads to a loss of function of
the gene entirely or it could be even
more complicated than that and the te
could introduce methylation to the
surrounding region and silence the gene
entirely and so for a large complex
trait like yields um tees have been
shown to impart really subtle effects on
Fitness and this was another study I was
a part of that's now on bioarchive that
showed that individuals who had more
tees had um uh uh showed lower grain
yield in the ma namam hybrids and making
a number of assumptions on per plant
yields and planting density and the
number of kernels per year this came out
to losing around one to eight kernels
per additional 14 megabases
at and the question kind of Still
Remains though um if these same small
effects occur for smaller molecular
phenotypes like gene expression um like
they do for
yields so the key questions for this
project were do tees impact gene
expression within the Maze imds and
hybrids and if so at what distances do
these effects occur at uh what te
families cause the largest effects and
if so are there any known patterns among
those families and last how much
expression variance do these tees
actually explain and do they mimic some
of the large domestication loai or um
are they more subtle like
yields and so to do this uh we use the
high quality ma n genome sequences that
were releas released a few years ago um
and we also collected around 372 RNA
samples uh from both the ma inbred
founder parents and then also hybrids
between b73 and two other testers we
collected RNA samples from across four
different tissues and Quantified our
expression counts with salmon and then
for our te annotations we used the ones
that were generated as part of the N
Genome Project and so they were the
Eda te
annotations and so to actually model the
effect of tees on expression we chose to
calculate the number of te base pairs in
non-overlapping window of Windows
Upstream of each gene um and so for this
example even though it looks weird the
gene transcribes over to the left I know
it looks funny but I'll explain the
other parts of the model and hopefully
makes sense um so here we go oh no that
really SPS okay so um we know that
there's tees Upstream of each gene and
we also know that there are uh or DNA
methylation plays a large role in
whether or not genes are expressed and
we know that unmethylated genes tend to
be expressed and so we layer on
unmethylated regions on top
um and then we go window by window and
count the number of te base pairs
occurring within that window and the
number of unmethylated regions also
occurring in that window and we do that
for every window Upstream up to 15 KB
away from genes and then we do that for
all the other genes that are present in
the
genome and so we take all of those model
components and then we build a model
that actually asks what is the effect of
expression um uh with te base pairs in
the number of unmethylated
regions and so this plot is showing the
uh Gene there we go oh no it's not
showing okay it's showing the gene that
again transcribes to the left and
multiple distances going away from that
Gene and uh the yellow line shows the
count of unmethylated regions um and the
effect estimate on the y- axis from the
model and we can see near the core
promoter of genes te um or sorry
um yeah near the core promoter
unmethylated regions are really
important and that makes sense because
unmethylated genes tend to be expressed
in terms of tees we find a weekly
negative effect of tees uh te base pairs
when they insert within the core
promoter along with another more weakly
negative effect uh near the actual
promoter of genes and this kind of
suggests that um there uh tees are
imparting subtle negative effects when
they insert into core regulatory regions
and that makes sense because they might
be potentially
deleterious one of the main problems
though with this model is that it's
looking across all te families and all
of these families differ really greatly
by their insertion preferences their
actual sequence content and the also
physical size of the te
itself and so this is an example just
looking at the differences of te length
on the Y AIS between DNA transposons and
retrotransposons and Maze and
retrotransposons or Retros tend to be
much larger in general than DNA
tees kind of looking at this plot in a
different way in my data um this plot is
looking at the proportion of te families
that fall into four different size
categories uh based on their cumulative
abundance across Nam and so for very
large te families the ones on the bottom
there's only 48 of them in my data set
that make up um you know that are over a
100 megabases in n and they actually
make up like 50% of the N genome but
there are there's an overwhelming
majority of really small te families out
there that still could potentially cause
effects even though they don't
contribute a lot of total base
pairs and so in order to see if there
was an effect between smaller tees and
really large tees I grouped them into
these four different size categories and
ran the same model as before seeing if
there's an impact of gene expression um
and te base pairs given in each one of
these small
families and so this is just looking at
one DNA transposon in the top 5% of te
families causing the largest effects on
gene expression and this is a DNA te a
helon um and so we can see a long
distance there's a variable effect of
this one te family a long distance and
if we look at the other small families
they tend to cause the largest overall
absolute effects on expression versus
much larger families which are in all of
the different colors here and so overall
yes we do see an effect uh with te size
and we also see an effect by distance
and so we're still looking into what a
lot of this means and whether or not
it's just highlighting um like the te
family insertion preference into these
different regions or if it's actually
something more
biological and so all of our past models
have shown that distance is really
important in determining if a te has an
effect or not and so we wanted to run a
more simplified model just with distance
to see what that effect was and so we
took the number of Bas pairs until the
first insertion from a particular family
and so this one would be the first mint
te the first blue te family and the
first orange one and then we do this for
all the other te families and first
insertions of that
family and so this is what our model
looked like we just took expression
against distance for each family
separately and did the same model for
each family
separately and this plot is looking at
the median distance to that family
by the uh partial adjusted r squar on
the y- axis of how much variation it
actually explains in expression and
around one KB away from genes tends to
have the largest effects on expression
um and uh I should also explain that the
color of the points uh sorry my bad uh
refers to the number of genes that uh te
was present near and so the largest
effect tees tend to be present in very
few genes overall tees that are present
in more than a thousand genes don't tend
to cause any uh large effects
whatsoever and so the top five families
that contribute to these effects tend to
be things like helitrons and other DNA
tees along with one LTR
retrotransposon um and a lot of the
future work in the next coming months is
going to be towards validating some of
these effects and and trying to
determine if there's any patterns in the
genes that they insert
here so the key takeaways from this
project um tees and known regulatory
regions decrease gene expression um and
they tend to be near the core promoter
or actual promoter of the Gene and these
are known regions already that are
enriched for open chromatin or TF
binding sites so it makes sense that
tees would impart more of a negative
effect there um next is that small te
families tend to have the largest
effects and uh last is yeah te families
only explain explain a fraction of the
variance in the cyst regulatory
expression in the small subset of genes
that they actually insert near and this
suggests that the ma Geno might uh be
using selection to restrict large effect
te insertions and in favor of more small
effect
ones and so most of my work until this
point has shown that quantitative traits
are highly polygenic and that any
candidate Loi that we find will have
incredibly small effects and a lot of
this is dictated by uh Alan or's work
and along with Fisher's geometric model
um that uh that says as a a population
gets closer to its Fitness Optimum um
such as maze um the the smaller and fall
smaller those effects will actually be
and this makes sense because ma is
undergone domestication already and so
any trait that we're looking at now will
have really small effects overall
um and so for yields the most complex
and quantitative of all traits we
wouldn't expect anything
different and this Segways into my last
project on yield testing that was
published in nature last
year so this is sparked by um a lot of
papers that have been published over the
last 20 years that say um that they can
increase yields by anywhere from 8 to
68% through a single Gene but one of the
main problems is that these results
never translate into to uh real yield
gains on farm and after reading a lot of
these papers and running a structured
review of them I found that they have a
lot of common problems among them and
these problems are things like a
misunderstanding of what yield actually
is and how yield components contribute
to that um this also has to do a lot
with measuring single plant yield versus
plot
yields uh next is not matching on Farm
conditions so a lot of folks are not
testing an elite germ plasm and having
confounding um Edge and density effects
that lead to misleading yield estimates
there's also uh questions of scale with
hand harvesting versus mechanically
harvesting these
experiments there's also insufficient
environmental and plot replication and
so there's a good number of greenhouse
onlys and this typically isn't a problem
if you're trying to do like a proof of
concept experiment but when you're
saying you know four plants grown in a
greenhouse are going to change the face
of Agriculture forever it starts to
become a problem so yeah um there's also
very little plot or environment
replication and testing for yield
effects in only a sing year um there's
also a lot of testing genes that might
have already been fixed within breeding
programs and also
um looking at yield effects in leals
that have been segregating within
breeding populations for the past few
decades and often when you read really
closely within these papers you find
that there are a lot of trade-offs with
other yield components um in those
yields so um it's good to think about
when you bring those uh particular yield
alals to
fixation and the last is lack of
controls and so a lot of folks don't
have empty Vector controls or don't
backcross their varieties into
non-transformed varieties or Elite
varieties to kind of clean up some of
those background epigenetic effects that
can occur during or during the the
transformation
process and so I talk about the L two
within my paper and you can read about
those there as so I am just going to
dive a little bit deeper into the first
three and so for a misunderstanding of
yield and yield components yield is
typically the weight of the dry grain or
the dry matter content of the storage
organs harvested per unit area and so
what a lot of these papers tend to do is
measure differences for example in Grain
length for example between a wild type
and a mutant and say that that increase
in like a quarter of a mill of grain
length is then going to translate into
plot wide yield later on the same goes
for changes in Grain length or
differences in Grain fill between a wild
type and you another one of my favorites
is measuring biomass changes in a rabid
opsis and saying that that will then
translate into prop
plants and
so um it only or 40% or that's a lot of
them uh of the studies in my review uh
measured yields within single plants or
measured y components and pass that off
as as their yield
increase one of the main problems with
this though is that increases in
individual yield components or single
plant yields won't necessarily uh scale
especially um the it doesn't imply that
yield per area will
increase and this is beautifully
exemplified in a lot of Donald duvic's
work looking at the year of hybrid
introduction in the uh Pioneer M
breeding program from starting in the
1930s up to the 2010s
and it shows that when a variety is
planted at incredibly low density older
hybrids tend to yield just as much as
newer hybrids however when you increase
the density older hybrids are incredibly
outcompeted by newer hybrids in general
and this implies that single plant yield
hasn't really changed over time however
the yield per unit area has and that has
been a selection Target in maze breeding
programs over the past Century and kind
of scarily only 16% of the studies in my
review actually planted at commercially
relevant densities quite typically
they're at incredibly low densities and
that will skew yield estimates in and of
itself up next is insufficient
environment and plot replication and so
this is an example from wheat looking at
the wheat or yield within a plot uh
starting from the center and going out
to the edge and you can see as you go
out further to the edge those yield
estimates will increase because those
plants along the edge have more access
to light and nutrients and all those
good things and so they'll yield more
typically what folks do is only measure
the stuff on the
inside and something else that can
impact uh just plot yield in general is
competition between plants and so a lot
of studies don't tend to actually have
border rows or put really competitive
genotypes next to each other and that
will skew a lot of these estimates
there's also small plots in terms of the
physical size of the plot and the number
of individuals that can lead to
unreliable data and a whopping 92% of
the studies had experimental designs
that would amplify Edge effects so it's
something to keep an eye out for and
yeah a very few studies actually
measured yields within the center rows
in for example in a four row plot
discarding the outer two rows and only
harvesting the
center some last Quick stats on this um
in terms of plants per plot it varied
from anywhere from four plants to 900
and 900 is is approaching the scale of a
small scale yield trial but still the
there's around 40% of the studies
measured less than 20 plants terms of
plot replication 46% of them uh measured
in less than three plots overall and
typically this was only in a single year
and in terms of multiple year testing
only us 63% of them tested in less than
three years of testing so very little
validation often goes into some of these
large high impact papers which is kind
of scary
um in terms of not um or limited testing
in Elite germ plasm this is an example
from tobacco looking at tobacco yields
in a bunch of commercial uh tobacco
hybrids and petite Havana and petite
Havana has been used in a lot of studies
because it can be transformed but it's
also been used for a lot of yield
estimates and uh some high impact papers
and the funny thing is is that petite
Havana yields 1,600 per less than its
commercial competitive counterparts so
uh quite the difference um and 46% of
the studies did not test an elite germ
plasm and so this is a really common
one
um one of the um favorite analogies that
I've heard for testing an elite
germplasm is like changing a single part
in a Model T versus a Ferrari and so um
Model T is not Elite or competitive and
so any Improvement that you make to it
will seem great um but it's limited in
its frame and its design by how fast it
can go given that
Improvement but one of the main
arguments that I've gotten is that
they're available to academics to
actually test they're transformable so
that's why folks use them and this is as
opposed to something like a Ferrari
that's Elite it's commercially
competitive and so any Improvement that
you make to it will already add to a um
optimized engine and design but uh for
these typically they're only available
to folks within industry or breeders
themselves given patent variety
protection and outside of plant breeding
most folks don't know that X patent
variety protected lines exist for them
to test um and actually validate effects
in and I would kind of refer to these as
kind of like guyer's car and diners
dive-ins and drives they are fairly
competitive lines um and so any
improvements that you make in Yi can be
realistically tested in somewhat quality
germ plasm and the best part is that
they are available to academics to test
in so it's good
ticket so bringing all of these things
together I grouped a lot of the things
that I talked about into three General
categories and so they things like um
controlling for moisture did they um
avoid Edge effects in their experimental
design did they replicate their
experiments um you know uh uh and did
they test an elite germ plasm and if the
study did that thing correctly I gave it
a green box if they didn't do it well I
gave it a black box and if it was
unclear if that information wasn't
provided I gave it a different color and
so looking across studies no one thing
consistently goes wrong within them each
of these studies shows a variable
experimental design and quality and so
it's really important to check for a
number of different things when
evaluating the quality um of these
experiments and it's important to note
that no single yield Gene has ever been
commercialized and it's not from a lack
of trying and this is as far as we can
tell in the public data even though two
genes have gone through regulatory steps
and I'll talk about one of them in the
next slide but um this is one of my
favorite papers within the space it's
from Carl Simmons and it looks at a two
decade long industry breeding program
where they tested 1,600 genes from 47
different species at scale in the field
and they looked at things things uh for
growth and yields like water use
efficiency nitrogen use efficiency all
different kinds of traits and they found
that of these 1600 genes only eight of
them significantly contributed to yield
all the rest were either nonsignificant
in Gray or significantly drug down
yields um in the environments that they
were tested
in the only Gene that has shown a lot of
evidence and has gone through regulatory
approval has been zmm 28 and it's amaz
or ma uh domestication transcription
factor that across most of the
environments and conditions it was
tested in increases yield by around 2%
and one this is extraordinary because
you could statistically actually test
for a 2% yield Gene but then one or the
second thing is that this Gene actually
exists um which feels very
rare very modest but rare um and so
given that a lot of these single yield
genes consistently get published in high
impact journals I found it necessary to
write more of a policy piece uh to
ensure that yield testing uh is more
robust going forward and to do this I
assembled a team of global domain
experts from across the fields of
quantitative genetics plant breeding
molecular biology and population
genetics to write this perspective
piece and I'll say right now that all of
these yield testing criteria aren't
novel they're all written about in fiser
1935 design of experience expent they're
uh published in kelb back's uh PhD
dissertation from the University of
Nebraska Lincoln in 1917 so they've been
around for a while and those are back in
the day when uh Planters Used to Be Drug
behind horses and they could still make
plots
well and so the criteria that we came up
with were things like using standard
definitions of yield and so this is
measuring plot yields versus single
plant yields um this is testing for
genotyp type by environment by
management effects it's matching on Farm
conditions and so this is thinking about
plant competition and density and Edge
effects as you're creating your
experimental blocks um and it's also
following on Farm practices for planting
and harvesting and fertilizer um
applications there's also prioritizing
genes that plant breeding may have
missed or uh checking to see that
they're not already fixed within
commercial breeding
programs using appropriate controls and
Elite germ plasm and so testing those
empty Vector controls and wild types and
then also developing collaborations
because no one person knows how to do
all of these
things and to kind of conclude all of
these different projects in a mixed bag
of a slide um anywhere from 1 to 32% of
intervals show some sort of plot tropy
in Maze and most of this is noise
imparted through the gws process for
tees we found that primarily small tees
that insert into known regulatory
regions lead to the largest negative
effects on gene expression and for
yields we redeveloped a set of yield
testing standards to robustly test for
effects in the field and hopefully this
will help researchers and reviewers in
the future uh critically analyze this
body of
work and a couple key lessons that I
learned through my PhD I slipped this
off into more scientific and personal
ones but the first is I can never escape
the constraints of Fisher and or they
are two people that are always is there
for me and they always bring me small
effects um a lab motto has been fail
fast and I would build on that and say
building and nurturing the strength of
fail fast is really um and and trusting
yourself in that process is really
helpful to you know growth or my growth
and development as a
scientist and also I've used social
media a lot especially Twitter as a
platform for positive change within our
scientific Community to one call for
more rigor within yield testing studies
that led to the nature paper but then
also serving as you know probably some
grad students reviewer number two and
correcting all of their yield things um
and the second is calling for more
cultural change within our scientific
societies that will hopefully end up
leading to better environments for our
black brown and Indigenous uh
scientists in terms of her or personal
things um I found that Community is
really important and I'll talk about
mine in the next slide they're the folks
that help keep you sane throughout this
process and the last is you yourself are
the most important project that you will
ever work on during your time at Cornell
and no scientific project is worth your
mental or physical well-being and so
we're all here to develop and to learn
and to grow and so as long as you
yourself are doing better than you
yourself yesterday you're already
winning in terms of finding Community
I've been really lucky to be a part of
synapsis and the indigenous grad Student
Association ation over the past few
years that have provided a lot of great
uh friendships and uh sounding boards
for things um I'd also like to say thank
you to my family for supporting me this
entire time and through this very
stressful process so I'm very thankful
for them I'm also thankful to a lot of
the mentors that have helped me along
the way and these are the folks that
taught me genetics and statistics folks
that have helped me through a lot of
different projects and encourage me to
get into some of my first research
experiences as well as folks that to
have helped me move on to the next stage
of my career and find jobs along with my
mom who's filming all of this from the
back supporting me this whole
time um I'd also like to say thanks to
the mentors that are no longer with us
uh my Master's CIS adviser Don o passed
away in 2021 and he always said that for
this talk he'd be uh he'd drive here and
sit in the front row and so that's why
there is a seat with the blanket uh
reserved for
him uh and last but not least I'd like
to thank the uh buckler lab for all of
their help throughout various projects
my committee Cedric and wch um along
with the American Indian and Indigenous
studies program if not for them I
wouldn't have written my last three
papers or dissertation and so very
thankful for them um and I have been
funded over the past few years by an Nea
pre-doctoral Fellowship um and that's
been great and so with that I'd be happy
to take any
questions a question and a comment I
wonder if you're finding that player
chopy plays a smaller role than folks
previously bought is related to the fact
that maybe we can now dissect phenotypes
better like we understand what a
phenotype is and and what are distinct
phenotypes
then yeah I think a lot of it has to do
with the type of Association models that
people were using before because a lot
of Pat tropy was called the qtl studies
and that just makes it seem like a whole
chromosome arm is significant as opposed
to gwas that gives
you a likely list of candidates that are
causal um and so yeah my comment is that
actually is also kind of form of a
question that the last bit that you
talked about I wonder to what degree you
think that these
over extending of of validity of R of
scientific papers it's driven by the
people who WR them or the the editors of
journals that push folks particularly
these highly visible
papers I I you know if I was to play
play play the play my suggestion would
be 80% editors % people who submit to
pressure I wonder what your thought is
that you actually very carefully read
all those papers yeah I think it's a
little bit of a mixed bag I think a lot
of the responsibility goes to editors
because they are responsible for finding
the correct peer reviewers for these
kinds of articles
that typically these yield studies tend
to only be like a couple of sentences or
a table in the supplementary info and so
they typically try to find reviewers
that can cover the majority of the paper
versus a couple sentences and I think
that's a lot of the reason why these
things can get published eventually um
but they also attractive yeah they are
also highly cited and uh really yeah
well used so it's it's
yeah dear superb talk thanks I had a
related question to voyex about
publication I mean plant gentic as a
whole has just churned out massive
volumes of gws studies most of those
hits don't get used and it's always felt
like a part of that is that a gws fits
in a dissertation and a variety doesn't
12 years to make a variety three years
you know field trial plus analysis and
writing for a GS same with qil maing
before it and test out five GS models
after it have you thought as somebody's
thought like really heavily and looked
at these and and looked at 25 of them
very intent and thought about them int I
mean have you do you have thoughts on
one if you feel like that statement I
just made is true and then two if you
have thoughts about how in a field where
start to finish the process takes 12
years nobody wants to stay for that for
PhD what how we could how we could
mitigate that and start having more
things that are relevant to variety
development but that fit within a 5 six
year time
span yeah that's a little hard
um solve the
field I mean in the second version of
our guilt paper like we talk about ways
in which to describe your results in a
way that's not like this Gene will
change the future of Agriculture and
increase yield by like 50% it's more
modest in that like future or additional
testing that's needed before it can be
used in the field or you know talking
about it differently with industry part
partners for example who have the better
abilities at scaling this and so in that
way you still get a paper that's still
important and show the importance of a
gene but um yeah
it's it's hard when the the cycle of
Academia is really short and dependent
on a grad student or a postto and it's
hard to say where the responsibility
lies in some of these larger projects
but I would say write about the results
a little bit differently and and go from
there
Mark says he's gonna use this paper in
his class that's
cool I'm sorry to Future grad
students it already is being used at a
number of
universities yeah uh no questions in the
chat yeah so the the genes that are
essentially having no relationship to
yield are
they and this might be more of a
speculative question but are they genes
that are not actually scaling up and
have no relationship to yield or do you
think that they are genes that have
something that is relevant but only to
that scaled down experiment for instance
maybe that field did not have enough
water and so it's actually a drought
related Gene that actually
increased
uh I think they're typically sometimes
only good in some of those smaller
experiments there have been a number of
studies from industry looking at how
variable these single Gene effects are
by environment and they show just
gigantic G by effects and
so for any one of these genes to
actually go through the regulatory
process it costs like hundreds of
millions of dollars in order to do all
the safety all the yield trials in
different locations and so whenever an
industry uh company wants to
commercialize one of these genes they
need to make sure that it's stable
across the majority of environments that
it's in and so that's why zmm 28 is one
of those rare exceptions of like they're
not willing to pay $200 million for a
one environment one condition kind of
yield Gene as opposed to something that
will work well across a lot more
hopefully that answers your
question did I make a comment as
supposed asking a
question uh I just wanted to say that I
there's an uncommon amount of wisdom in
the talk that you just gave as opposed
to results and you know schol analyses
or whatever it's a different order of
things and so my comment has to do is is
one that I want everybody to hear I'm a
little scared about saying this
but two things that you said that that
are really strong one thing that you
said was I was never meant to be here
and the other thing that you said was uh
cultural change is a really important
thing
so I just want to make sure that our
audience is hearing that and thank
you
[Laughter]
thanks question yeah thank you
for I'm kind of interested about your
take like what would be the evolutionary
role of Lop be and transposable elements
in your opinion regard more on the
backseat or dri that opportunity
I think they might lead to some of the
larger adaptive changes especially tees
themselves because some of these effects
have led to some of the really large
domestication genes for example or
radical changes in gene expression
especially under like stressful
conditions like salt or drought a lot of
tees can get activated and so I think
there is a really large impact even
though right now for things like yields
it doesn't seem like it um and as for
Pat
tropy I I still think it exists I still
think it's out there but a common
limitation to what we're doing is that
gwas can only look for petrop and common
variants because you need like
segregating alals you could still have
Pat tropy at fixed Loi like TV1 um
because you have a lot more safety in
fixation you can't lose critical
functions if that Gene gets lost or um
yeah the Leal frequency changes and it's
no longer prevalent in population and so
it it still has some effect but not uh
M oh we don't need bonus slides okay
uh your thoughts on canidate Gene
identification could be refined for re
relevance to Elite germ plasm and
breeding programs often we rely on
insights from gws and very diverse
Association panels which typically don't
have as much applied relevance in
structured breeding
programs
um so that I'm not sure sometimes going
to other species and finding genes that
haven't already been tested for a long
time within the same species can help um
some of even the yield genes that have
been published before do have a lot of
Promise because sometimes they're
introduced from different speces and you
can have novel effects that haven't been
tested so maybe there um is a start
hope it answers your
question thank us for May providing us
wisdom this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu